Unknown: Don't say let us continue this transmission. Now, first and foremost, before we begin with the meditation,
the electronic experience that you had when we disconnected from the channel, is because we didn't completely disconnect.
We thought we'd give you a tiny taste of what's coming up on the 13th with regard to the idea of our presence being a little bit closer, by allowing you
to match our heartbeat.
So
this is the very beginning of things to come expressed first in the energy of your devices, but coming closer and closer and closer
Peace care
unless you find it fun.
And now, allow yourselves to relax.
Let go of the cares of the dare. Take a deep breath in and let it out.
And continue to breathe deeply and easily as you allow your lights to shift and your music to play,
and to begin
the journey
to the portal
at midnight, under the hunter's moon,
because you can begin to project yourselves there now ahead of the physical date, since all things are here and
Now,
so be with us now.
In that vortex in Joshua Tree at midnight, under the full Hunter's moon,
stand upon the ground, sit upon the ground lie upon the ground, whatever is your wish
and gaze up at the stars and the moon in the clouds of the night sky.
As you feel the energy bill
with anticipation
of an opening
of a door
slowly opening
wider
and wider and wider
so that you may see
through to the other side, a dimensional doorway, a portal, a vortex.
And on the other side,
other forms of consciousness peeking through that door at you
watching, observing,
feeling the invitation you have sent
by the opening of the door
and that consciousness passes through the door, crossing the threshold into your reality
still hovering in the sky
observing you all and awaiting the signals,
receiving the signals the vibrations, the frequencies
of your inner being
letting those frequencies
Wash over and through the other consciousness,
taking it in absorbing,
feeling it,
reading it
and then
silently at first and then as a whisper,
speaking to you,
casting spells of energy, in the language of light
that crystallize in your consciousness as symbols, images, feelings, translations, ideas, imaginations.
uncharted territories unfold in the map of your mind
as the stars across the sky.
Connect in your imagination, two lines of
Light, forming asterism constellation
that allow you to chart a course not only upon your planet, but through the cosmos.
To rise upward,
whether standing, sitting or lying down to rise up or to meet, the consciousness that descends towards you
and to feel your heart open
as its heart opens to you,
and to meet,
in the middle, in the sky,
in the stars in the clouds in the night,
under the light of the moon
that illuminates not only the landscape around you,
but the soul within you
The mind within you, the spirit within you, illuminates every cell of your being
and calls forth
the true self.
We're not it says,
For we are your family. We are those parts of yourself
that you do not yet know, but will come
to understand, will come
together when
will come to know deeply
and the more deeply you know yourself, the more deeply you will know us.
For we are but mirrors
and in us is reflected
the grace
and potential
You're being
dance with us now among the star.
Be open in your vision and your senses to go beyond
what you normally conceive of as your reality, to drop the veils and the barriers and see coming forth
a spread of lights, a spread of stars
that are not stars, but beings of consciousness.
And though the stars themselves also have their own form and expression of consciousness,
these come to you as extensions as sparks of light and life.
And as you meet them and as you match them,
The spark within you ignites
and shall forevermore burn bright
and shall forevermore be within.
As a light in the lantern that lights your way that lights your path.
The path that is you
be open on this night, under the hunter's moon.
For what you are hunting for is yourself.
What you seek is more of you.
It is not game that you hunt, but knowledge of the game that you play
on her
knowledge of the scene you have chosen to explore.
Under the hunter's moon all can be revealed
You can find your place upon the earth in the grand scheme of the game
and allow yourself to play out your self chosen freewill destiny. As you the unique you that is now held in the sight of other consciousnesses, other hearts, other minds other souls other spirits other beings.
We hold you in our hearts
and welcome
to our world
as you welcome us to you.
We meet here in this place at this time
under this moon in this light
This meeting shall be forever here and now.
So that even as you walk your path, in the light of day,
the hunter's moon
shall gleam within you, glow within you.
And Lori, you, attract you magnetize you to more of yourself, to hunt for those pieces within you that will allow you to connect,
to integrate, to join, to blend, to harmonize
and to constantly
with curiosity
burning in your heart to seek more and more and more of your being
and see yourself reflected
In the million shards
of the shattered mirror,
that is all that is.
That are the stars in the sky.
The mirrors that reflect the spark within each and every one of you
come to this place.
This
is the first meeting of many that shall grow
and crystallize
into physical form
one day
not too far away.
So be here now, in this place
at this time and on this day
of the 13th of October
in the ending of an old cycle and the beginning of a new
that begins with your year of 24. Within that is not only
the promise of perfect vision of a future,
but the clarity of hindsight from which you can learn to be here and now in the present.
Using the power of the illusion of the past and the future, to inform yourself
of the knowledge you need in the here and the now
Be at peace, be enjoy
and feel the beating of your hearts.
That the rhythm of your breath
as you breathe in
and out,
in and out
and journey deeper than ever before into the great mystery
of all that is
continue now, as your lights fade and your music fades into the night.
The Night of the hunter's moon
continue to float
and dream and be just be just real
Just be
the light
that surrounds you,
that encompasses you,
that unfolds
and that nurtures you and that blesses you with insight
that shall guide you
along the way, on your journey with us, hand in hand, heart and heart